[Music]
from the moment we wake up we're
bombarded
it's hard to say exactly when it
happened or even how but at some point
not long ago misinformation became
mainstream
the claims were debunked several years
ago conspiracy theories crawled out of
the dark corners of the internet and
began shaping world events
the u.s capitol rides
vaccine mandate protests
the war in ukraine all driven by
disinformation
there is a common thread between them
and that's that the information
environment has become toxifying you
can't sustain a society if
people can't agree on basic facts
imran ahmed runs a non-profit called the
center for countering digital hate he
and his team find and fight online
misinformation and hate speech from
their offices here in washington dc hey
carl how you doing i'm all right yeah
not too bad and here in london uk
can we go through a few things that
we've been working on they recently
examined 1300 facebook posts from
russian state media and found despite
its previous pledge that facebook had
failed to label 91 now their initial
reaction was actually to deny our
research including this one promoting
the conspiracy theory that the united
states is secretly funding biological
weapons labs in ukraine facebook said it
would put these labels on there the
baseless claim first took off on twitter
if you were hearing about the biolabs it
was me
before being picked up by russian and
chinese officials
followed by fox news what exactly are
they doing in these secret ukrainian bio
labs the labs aren't a secret the
international community openly funds
research labs in ukraine and other
countries to protect against infectious
diseases
but that didn't stop russia from
spreading the lie
putin has invaded a sovereign country
and the first weapons he used in that
war against ukraine were not missiles or
tanks it was disinformation and lies
spread through propaganda on social
media
and imran knows firsthand how
disinformation and lies can be deadly
back in 2016 he worked in london for the
british opposition labour party boris
you should know the months leading up to
the brexit referendum were littered with
false racist claims about migrants and
refugees
one of imran's closest colleagues labor
mp joe cox there's growing evidence as
we know was campaigning against brexit
when she was shot and stabbed to death
in the street
witnesses say her murderer shouted
britain first i saw him pulling the gun
out
in the days before he'd accessed a long
list of white supremacist websites and
social media posts i mean i was one of
the first people to hear the news
because i was in head office at the time
and
i cried
it is the misinformation that underpins
the certainty they have such certainty
that he's willing to murder a mother of
two
to achieve his ends there is no question
anymore
that online hate and disinformation have
a real world impact and that question is
is settled the question now is what do
we do about it
imran's answer
is this
there is an active failure to act soon
after cox's death he left british
politics and launched his organization
the center for countering digital hate
calling on social media companies we
have the right to have information that
isn't being sullied deliberately it
doesn't matter if it's true or not to
crack down on misinformation and hate on
their platforms what they're doing is
trying to overwhelm our defenses at the
time six years ago when i was telling
everyone look this is being inculcated
on facebook people laughed people said
facebook that's where i see what my
grandkids are doing and of course people
didn't get it people would say to me but
it's the internet it's not the real
world no one's asking me anymore is
there a real world cost for online hate
and misinformation
the six years since joe cox was killed
have witnessed an explosion of extremism
then people keep saying it's uncanadian
people keep saying these the things that
are happening in america un-american i
keep saying that brexit was kind of
unbritish
very moderate people and yet these
extreme things are happening but they
are becoming perfectly canadian american
and british because that's the world
that we now live in and if a user
engages with misinformation on social
media they're likely to be fed more
creating a convergence of conspiracies
if you like anti-vaxx it will feed you q
and on and anti-semitism and vice versa
if you like anti-semitism it will drive
you covert disinformation and vaccine
disinformation so you see this deepening
and broadening of extremism that's how
they design their platforms they're
delighted is the truth
because if people are consuming more and
more conspiracy theories they don't go
to the library for it they stay on
platform and the longer a user stays on
platform the more ads they see the more
money that platform makes
an addictive loop of disinformation and
hate
that once consumed lauren manning look
at that look now there's the there's one
to use there's the look growing up in a
mostly white middle-class suburb near
toronto lauren never felt like she fit
in when she was 16 her dad died from
cancer she felt angry and alone i was
close to him so i was looking for
someone or something to attach myself to
the following year in 2007 she was
posting on the facebook page of her
favorite heavy metal band when she
received a message from a stranger he
was fairly careful around me he wasn't
dropping racial slurs right away so
eventually um the narrative that he had
given me was well okay you know all the
people at your school that you don't
like how you talk about them being
elitist you should meet some jews you
should see how elitist they are
before long lauren was a full tattooed
member of a white supremacist group
1488 stands for white power and heil
hitler she attended meetings and got
into fights it was a very painful time
for a family you know when you blame
yourself as a parent you take on a lot
of guilt her mother jeannette eventually
gave her daughter an ultimatum choose
her family or her hate group i was
heartbroken when she chose them and she
left and i just sat and i cried but
after a while she began to question the
group's claims
one of her friends was stabbed to death
in an unrelated attack but the group
lied and claimed he'd been targeted
because he was white
after five years lauren finally removed
her tattoos and announced she planned to
leave the white power group in response
she was attacked beaten and hospitalized
for a week we used to say that we're
fighting for the freedom of the white
race however there was nothing freeing
about being trapped in that web
i
had wrapped my entire identity around
this movement so the biggest question
was okay how am i going to find myself
again
today after eight years lauren is
finally free
both she and her mother now provide
counseling and support for others who
find themselves or their loved ones
trapped in extremist groups
jeanette says these days it seems
everyone knows someone who has become
consumed by conspiracies
i don't think the governments have
realized how epidemic it is
and those digital predators now have a
new hunting ground i mean this is it
callum hood part of imran's team in
london goes undercover in virtual
reality he recently spent 12 hours on vr
chat a third-party facebook app
users wearing headsets equipped with
microphones appear as avatars and
interact in a virtual world fake dragons
that's you feel famous man facebook
calls this living in the future imran
describes it differently you have a
completely lawless environment
okay so you're you're gonna be my new
girlfriend okay callum recorded these
videos showing more than 100 instances
of verbal abuse
from racism let's get this black kid
to sexual assault
they occurred on average about every
seven minutes because it's all from that
first person perspective it's a level of
intensity that i think people find quite
shocking how people behave to each other
in in there that little
12 year old imran's team reported the
incidents to vr chat and facebook but
two months later he says there's been no
response you press the emergency button
and nothing happens if you're going to
build with safety at the heart of your
experience
they're going to have to put in a lot of
work to get this
as somewhere where parents would feel
safe leaving their kids because right
now you don't want mark zuckerberg
babysitting your kids
in an email the makers of vr chat told
global news they provide options to mute
or block abusive users
and moderators can also suspend or ban
those who violate their code of conduct
meta our mission remains the same
meanwhile a spokesperson for facebook's
parent company metta told global news
they're rolling out new safety measures
starting this month including parental
supervision tools to prevent children
from unlocking adult content
communicate with your friends across
different layers of reality they add
that meta employs third-party fact
checkers in 80 countries and 60
languages to remove or label
misinformation on their platform fewer
than 1 in 10 posts with links to russian
propaganda were being labeled meta also
says that imran's earlier claim that 91
of russian state media posts were
unlabeled is quote wildly inaccurate
saying that misinformation amounted to
less than one percent of all posts about
ukraine or russia but within days of
releasing his report imran says facebook
began cracking down so if you clicked on
the link it would actually say russia
state controlled media do you think that
labeling posts in that way makes any
real difference it's not the most
effective tool that they could do the
most effective is d platform if someone
breaks your rules again and again and
again by spreading misinformation which
is against your rules then take action
against them if you don't take action
what you're saying is the rules don't
matter there are no rules on our
platform as long as we're making money
if big tech companies won't take action
on their own imran is taking the fight
to them
holding meetings and addressing
lawmakers on capitol hill mr ahmed you
are recognized now for five minutes
social media companies cannot
self-regulate and in westminster we have
failed on multiple levels it's not
exactly a fair fight the parent
companies of facebook and google raked
in a combined 375
billion dollars last year imran's total
annual budget is 2 million
you're taking on some of the biggest
companies in the world do you feel a
little like david going against goliath
here our voice is one amongst billions
you're racist
there are millions of parents who are
worried about the impact of social media
on their children there are millions of
people who care about human rights
around the world and are worried about
the impact of social media on human
rights and on empowering the worst
actors among us i actually think that
we're the many and they are the few
and he believes change is coming
u.s lawmakers have proposed dozens of
different bills designed to make big
tech more accountable the european union
is close to enacting the most sweeping
reforms in the world and the canadian
government promised to introduce a new
digital charter this year positive moves
but imran worries still too little and
too slow
the last few years have been an
experiment in what if we privatize
political discourse and the way that we
communicate with each other and we hand
it over to a company who seeks to
maximize their profits
by picking out the stuff that makes us
most angry and engaged the enormous
greed the rapaciousness that underpins
the way that social media companies have
sought to change our societies for their
economic benefit that could destroy
democracy without that democracy we're
in real trouble